so for people out there who aren't
familiar uh
just tell me a little bit about your
background and how you got into stand-up
and and everything you do
um stand up i got in because
uh it was basically a dare someone dared
me a dare
yeah i used to i used to drink real
heavy you know
seven years off of that [ __ ] uh how old
are you by the way
33 33 okay same we're the same age oh
hell yeah you do not look 33.
1987 baby january
july oh okay yeah yeah close enough yeah
um
yeah someone did i was in college i was
cheering at uh
university of louisville uh on kentucky
and uh
you know my friends used to play these
acoustic
you know sets at bars you know and uh
we used to go see them all the time like
every it was like every monday night
we'd go see them
and uh one night they were playing and
um
they like called me up on stage and you
know
they just wanted me to [ __ ] say
something so only thing i knew was just
to
say something funny it wasn't like even
my attention but it was just like
well i can't come up here and just talk
you know like when it was [ __ ]
you know give a speech or something so i
just told like a funny story
and you know people were dying and then
uh
someone was like man you should get a
standup but i was like i don't [ __ ]
know anything
about stand up the only stand-up i
really knew at the time was uh
um eddie murphy raw
dave chappelle's killing him kill him
softly and uh
kings of comedy there's only ones i like
[ __ ] like strongly knew
but i didn't think that was like
something like anyone
could do i didn't think it was like oh
like you know anyone could just
[ __ ] be a stand-up comedian i thought
you like you know there was a lot more
to your whole life
yeah i thought it was like something you
you know especially knowing like
because what dave chappelle started when
he was like 15 so to eddie murphy so
like
i just thought that was like oh that's
you know that's something you got to
like get into like
yeah early on and um you know
and i used to be this you know drunk
where like
you know i was to say i want drunk you
know
that was a guy i was just waiting to get
there yeah yeah what say i won't do it
yeah
and someone's like uh yeah someone was
like you should you should try comedy i
was like i don't know anything about it
they're like yeah you won't do it i was
like say i won't
and then literally um you know found an
open mic
uh but like before i did that before i
even
found the open mic actually uh to
backtrack i've studied it for like
two months straight just like to
understand it
you know like when i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on like i don't know
anything about it
so i would just i would just watch
comedy like everybody like from
you know big names to random clips on
youtube
you know i just i just watch it just to
see um
what the [ __ ] i was getting myself into
right and uh
when i tried it you know um
i was blown away i was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
school
i can maybe do this yeah i was like i
you know
i was like i actually i was like i
enjoyed that and i was like and what i
did
you know that was the most studying i've
done for something you know
like i studied harder for that than i
did with school yeah yeah so
i was like yeah why would i why would i
do that
you know to myself you know like why
would i try to be somewhere where i just
don't give a [ __ ] yeah i just don't care
to be around it
yeah and um you know that was in uh
2010 and then once i did that man that's
why i was like oh okay
it's [ __ ] let's roll with it when you
were trying to learn it was there like a
point in time where you had
sort of an epiphany to like did you like
ever reach a certain point where like oh
i get it now
like uh you know what actually
um i stopped for two years after my
brother passed away
back in he passed away in 2013
and i want to say i in 2000 like all of
2014 2015 i didn't really do it
and um um in 2016
i when i got back up uh because of
friends just like they're like hey
you're going up tonight you know
and you know before they had said that
there was a lot of people asking me to
do shows and i kept
you know just turning people down i'm
like no i don't want to do it i don't
want to do it
and then uh when they were like oh
you're going up
i was like oh [ __ ] you know he's
guessing
i have a choice and um you know that was
the first time like
you know i said like real [ __ ] you know
what i mean and
people [ __ ] with it and like laughs
because you know
prior to that i mean like real [ __ ] like
the the stuff i was writing before you
know was just goofy stuff and trying to
like
i was really trying to be funny yeah i
was like
pushing like it was like so forced you
know
say this stupid thing yeah say that
stupid thing because it's stupid
you know but like it it it i didn't have
no connection to it
right you know whereas like when i got
back up
you know there was a connection to this
[ __ ]
it was real it was real some feeling in
it there was some feeling there was a
lot more meaning behind it
yeah and i felt better about being on
stage because of it
you know i think um i think
you know before i had quit you know it
stopped
i think i was just riding off this dare
you know that that someone you know i
was writing off that dare
of like yeah someone dared me to do this
but then you know
getting back on that's when it like
[ __ ]
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] yeah this is
what i should be doing you know that's
cool
and then it just [ __ ] you know i just
worked my ass off this back
home in arizona oh exactly you're
originally from arizona
yeah because i i um i moved back home
uh after i started comedy in louisville
yeah just
yeah i was like i just left college and
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah and i do not regret
that
of course yeah for college
not for everybody you know yeah love
college if you love college but [ __ ]
college
for people like me for most people
most people [ __ ] college unless you're
gonna be a doctor or unless you have to
get a degree that's what i'm saying i'm
like unless you like gotta [ __ ]
i mean i know so many people would great
jobs
that [ __ ] do not have a college
degree right they're as far as
oh yeah for sure yeah you just start
working for a company or whatever that
does
what you want to do and you just start
at the bottom and work your way up
that's the best way to learn
oh yeah one of my one of my friends i
think he's doing like 150 grand a year
something like that a year
[ __ ] high school diploma wow you know
working for like a you know
something with [ __ ] accounting i
don't know but he just like understood
though
yeah you know just you know works his
way up like literally
yeah from the bottom and just understood
the [ __ ] business so it's like yes
this person's [ __ ] good why would we
for everybody you don't gotta go to
college
yeah you can find your way yeah you can
find your [ __ ] way absolutely
and he ain't got no [ __ ] student
loans to pay off
or anything like that he don't owe sally
may you know
i